YouTube is very transparent so everyone
sees exactly how things are going in the
old days as an actor or maybe it's also
quite something with a musician maybe
that's why they get so stressed but like
everyone can see exactly how you're
doing on YouTube Every time so you're
only as kind of good as your last video
and I think no matter what people say
and they're like I don't care like how
it's going or whatever they look at that
and they're like [ __ ] that video is not
got 10 million views in a day I wanted
12. I find that you know the numbers wax
and Wayne when you see the analytics
just in front of you every single day
it's just like that's crazy last videos
[Music]
Beginning of the End like I'm irrelevant
now No One's Gonna care when you allow
the good to make you feel happy you're
not the bad to make you feel sad and so
you grow almost avoid getting too
excited when things are going well with
certain things because you've got to try
and find that happiness outside
foreign
[Music]